so
um let's start so my topic for today is
pwa for games and enhanced web gaming
experience
so we're going to like look what is pwa
and how can it be integrated for web
games so yeah
um before that is i would like to
introduce myself
i'm stephen vinoya i'm currently a
software development team lead at
go passport um a microsoft nbc
developers technology um community lead
for angular philippines so
we're also planning to have like a
conference on our
country philippines and it's more about
angular
because it's my like my breath and
butter when it comes to development
angular so and i also worked
as a part-time game developer so that's
why i got into
a little bit of game development because
it's my partner
i'm a part-time game developer and if
you happen to
um interested with meta i have a
website where i do post blogs there
it's one compilement.com
so one compartment is like um
a reference for an enemy one punch man
so
i'm an anime fan so that's why one
compartment because i like
doing codes before running it so i
i do a lot of coding before i run the
actual project
and yeah so here's my email as well
um gmail.com if you happen to be
interested
or you want to contact me afterwards you
can email me at that email
so yeah so now
um why are you here no
so what is the um the agenda that we
have for this
um topic so
the agenda that we're going to tackle
today is that
we're going to talk about three things
three major things we're going to talk
about what's pwa
a little bit of history about pwa and
since we're integrating pwa with game
development
so we're going to talk about what is web
game development
a little bit history of html5 beam
history
and we're going to run some samples and
demo
of course so we're i'm going to show
some of the
sample pwp games and
also the steps on how you can create
your own pwa games
and also a demo uh we will convert one
of my games into pwa
and of course we're going to have a q a
if we have enough time
so yeah that's basically our agenda for
this
thumbs up next is let's start
so let's start to define um what is pwa
i know most of you have already know
what pwa
is but it's still defined what is pwa
for those who don't
so according to my most reliable source
on the internet
which is wikipedia according to them pwa
or progressive web applications are web
applications that
load like regular web pages
um still works as regular web pages
or websites but it offers functionality
like working offline
push notification and it can access the
device hardware
which is traditionally available to the
native applications like android and ios
so
that being said a progressive web
application is a
application that can work offline and
has post notification
but later on we're going to discuss what
are the core
features that makes a website pwa
so that aside we're going to leave this
definition for now
and we're going to expand it a little
bit more as the slides
go on so next
um how did pwa originated
so um who invented or coined the term
pwa
so um in 2015 um
alex russell and francis berryman
complained
the term pwa or progressive web
application
to describe the applications taking
advantage
of the new features supported by modern
browsers which is the
service workers and the web manifest
so later on we're going to talk about
what are service workers and what is the
web manifest and how does
two functionality or files looks like
when you're actually coding it
and it lets the users upgrade the web
app into
progressive web application and can be
installed in your native
operating system
so when we say pwa so
when you say your application or your
website is a pwa
site it should be composed of these
pictures not all but
maybe some of it like it should be
installable
so your website should be installed
whether it's on a phone
or a desktop application so
later on we're going to see how can you
install
your pwa app inside your desktop or your
mobile application
next it should be responsive since
you're developing a site that can be
accessed to
mobile and web applications so it should
be fully responsive
connectivity independent meaning that as
i said before
it should work offline so it should be
connectivity independent meaning you can
work with or without an internet
connection once it's loaded
um apply crash ship
i'm discoverable and engageable so later
on we're going to talk about
why it should be safe why it should be
discoverable
or something like that so
um pwa is a website that should be
reliable
it should work offline and can load fast
it should be fast and engaging
so since we're installing the pwa app
it can be installed in your phone of
course it can be engaging because
you can just um click the application
inside your
desktop shortcut for um
so that being said i think
um to clear some confusion about what
is um let's
know or how can you know if a website
is a bwa website or not
so let's say for example twitter twitter
is
one of the websites that is pwa one of
the big websites
so to know one of the main features
so when you're accessing a twitter
website in your browser you can see this
plus uh plus icon besides the
favorite favorite button of the
website so when you click the plus icon
it will prompt you to install the
application
and if you choose install
you can see in your desktop or in your
mobile phone it should have
an application created in your as a
shortcut or
as a application so when you installed
it
it should create a clear application in
your
desktop or if you're using mobile
furniture create
an application in your home screen
another thing as i said before um pwa
can integrate or can maximize the
functionality of having a push
notification
so you can see there um
when the when you first load twitter it
it will
ask you if you should allow twitter to
use or show notifications
and it can really be engaging for you
because
um whether your the browser is opened or
not
you can still see the notifications
popping up on the right side of your
window
saying that someone tweeted someone
tweeted
someone to follow tweeted or
tweet something like that can really be
engaging because it can really notify
you
once there's notifications for you to
see
okay and um since i said before
um alex russell is the one that coined
the term pwa
it's an employee of google now of course
uh
google's browser which is chrome has the
ability
to detect if a pw if
a site is a pwa site or not
so to check if the site is pwa ready or
not
you can just simply go to the developers
console
click the lighthouse
and make sure that the
progressive web app category is
checked then you can just simply click
generate report so
after you click that one it should show
you
something like this uh which is it's
trying to emulate the website
and no internet connection and it's
trying to emulate the website in a
mobile
view so it's it should take a little
time
depending on your specific
specification of your computer so after
that
it will show you something like this
which will show you scores
for performance accessibility best
practices and seo
so what we want is to check if um our
website
pass the pwa checklist that
google is trying to establish so let's
click
after we click that one we can see
there is result so these are the
important checklists when you're trying
to make a bwa site
but for me i think this three is the
most
important one which is it should be
um deployed your site should be deployed
using ssl
so let's say for example you have
completed your pwa app and you're still
wondering why the
install application isn't popping up or
is it working for your site
and it's because probably you're not
deploying your site in an ssl or
ssl using ssl so it should be deployed
using https meaning it should have an
ssl
certificate on it and of course
um service worker are the ones that um
caches your um
caches your application and
register the code and make it
installable offline
and manipulate the json we're going to
look what manifest json
is but for those out there who is an
android or android developers probably
have heard of um the manifest thing
which is the
app manifest xml i think for android
correct me if i'm wrong and of course
since
you want your site to be installed
in many devices like tablets phone you
should have
different app icons with multiple sizes
computer
um to cater all of the applications that
you want it to be installed or the
devices that you want
it to be installed so yeah
so now let's um that's basically what
pwa is it's more about
um if you're trying to develop a pwa you
should like
check the lighthouse
all the criteria that makes your site vw
or not so yeah
so now let's move on to
the game part so
um since you're attending the talk about
pwa for games
i i assume that you like games
like you like developing games or you
like playing games
i think before you like to develop games
you should like to play games
i think so for me i think
you can also chat in chat in what is
your top three games
so later on in on slack or in private we
can
talk about what's your favorite team or
not so for me
uh my favorite games are um
securo so techie road
dark souls bloodborne and near automata
so i really am a good fan of
hack and slash games so um
i like those games so yeah
so for web so we have this um
aggregate io who among you here
have heard of this game i think it's one
of the most
famous games in web so
agar that i oh i think um has
accumulated 5 million
a day when it was released because of
the advertisement i guess
and also the number of players that
playing ever that
i owe and me as well used to play argo
that i owe when i was in college
because i use it as a pastime whenever
our professor is
around the laboratory so agree that i
was my game to go when
i was in college so yeah so
today is we're going to like look what
is
browser-based games so
um these four features are the
what you call this um the essential part
of
having a browser-based name so if you
don't have an internet connection this
um little dinosaur in chrome
will pop up and you can pay for it for a
while as long as you don't have internet
connection
and also there is flash so for those
people that have played before
in y8 uh what are the sets what i think
it's just white
for flash that is famous back then and
of course you can
develop develop web applications for web
beams using unity as well
and also the new standard or the the
most common thing is html5
[Music]
next is a little bit history on how
bbg or browser-based theme started so it
started
back in 1990 and it's they're using the
html or dynamic hypertext markup
language
and the main purpose of having a
browser-based game before
is just to make a casino game because um
computers are not that powerful back
then in 1990 so
and having a game to run in a website
will take a little bit more resources
because we're emulating a game inside
the website so
probably the most visible games back
before was making a casino game
the next is flash
on 1998 flash was introduced in
web beam development or browser-based
game development
and um
what is the company that
experimenting with micro media flash
and unfortunately um flash
isn't supported or has already died
just recently it's because um
iphone is one of the main reasons
which white flash is dead right now
because everyone didn't
support flash because it requires
some extensive processing for the
for the device itself and on 2014
um here comes the html5 you can now
develop without
having to code in flash or unity so just
javascript html and cs will do
so it's because it delivers features
like canvas webgl and web audio
so 2014 html5
and now since um
what are the most common html5
um game libraries out there so there is
spacer
i
which is if you're more into um
drag and drop scenario with less code
you should use construct for developing
your html5 games
there is um pjs um we call this
play canvas pixi.js
um 3js can also be used to develop teams
in 3d is unity
and there is you can also use p5.js
so um next is
let's have a look on how um 2d web games
just like for some of my 2d web games
so let's check
so unfortunately
i cannot show some of my company games
because i have signed
some mta so yeah so these are
um some of my games that i have created
um
this is a top down shooter game
so you can just like destroy enemies by
shooting at them
and they will just follow you wherever
you go just to kill you
yep so um later on i will post
post all the links for my games and you
and also the github repository
so you can check my my bad code
yep and of course uh let's
see what do i have here so i have also
sample tower defense so we can just
place towers here
and there's a particle system going on
there so this one is created using
pipe.js so yep
i personally like t5 for developing 2d
games because
it has this vector library which is
pretty easy to use when you are doing it
in freebie
and also let's show some games here
um i also have like this one which is
like
a flappy bird
so it's just like flappy bird with
with b on it
that one and
this one
so just just like that's the first one
flappy bird glow
which is um
and then the other one
um i also have this one which is
google jump like long game wherein you
have a bunny that jumps over a plan
and if you hit an enemy
and if you fall down to the platform and
also
it's name of demographic so next
is that is one of the sample um
combo games that they have but um let's
see
if let's see my
pwa games so
okay okay
so
yeah it's made it below
apk application so first let's start
with this one
this one is youtube game which is just
like a
copy of
catch up catch up catch up company
so basically you just put
stuff for breasts and
try to make it um
as tall as possible so if ever you run
out of labs
and it's game over
this one is also a pwa um
game but it looks and it works like a
neat
game for a native android game i would
say
so
so let's see how how can you install
a pwa dream
uninstall of my games so it has a splash
screen as well
going to talk about how can you set up
those things
and how can you change to splash clean
or not and
some stuffs like that so i'm going to
uninstall this one
and we can check how to make install
games or how can a pwa game
or a website should behave inside your
browser
so just let us click here just reload
the page
[Music]
okay
okay here we have it right
so yeah so when you're trying to access
a pwa website in your mobile phone
um you can see something like this
so let's say for example i have this
game tonight jump so for you
who didn't know what espomejo is panejo
is the
tagalog word for rabbit or we just
rabbit jump and make it
jump because it's like magnetic dialect
for
our native language for rabbit which is
coming here
so as you can see um there is this
add your name will jump to home screen
it's
the it's the one that's going to prompt
you to
install the game into your
home screen so it will complete
something like this at the home screen
so i
should add it to home screen and it
should
add it to home screen let's see
okay there we have it
yep and you can also uninstall the pw
web application if you like it or not
or something like that so that's what
makes
um pwa game engaging in a way that you
can install it
in your mobile phone or devices in
mobile devices so now um
let's move into all right let's move
into
some point of web video games and we're
going to
also see um how 3d games should be
converted to
and pwedem okay
so not just 2d but you can also convert
3d games into
pwa1 so i also have
some some of that not
not three um not pwa3d games so this one
uh if you have played near okamata this
game
is inspired by near automata
so it's a top down bullet hell shooter
games
it's a bit laggy because i'm sharing my
screen at the same time playing the game
but you can access the website it's
called
it can be accessed through one
compilement
backhander so you can play the game
and it has 25 levels on it so you can
have a pretty decent time playing this
one
so yep so that's one of my games
and now let's look onto
temple 3d games which i have
okay let's see this one alien runner
so it's a pwa game um it's loading
assets
for a while because it has 3d models in
it
let's wait well it loads the assets
and also the sounds
so there we have it so this one is a
clone
like um temple run but it's not
that good a step around with us and just
um i'm bad recording so
yeah basically that's our stream over
yeah basically this is it um
yeah basically that's it it's also a
pwa game but on 3d
okay so basically um you can
recreate what i need
a native android application should look
like
but it's not highly suggested to create
a 3d game in
pwa because of some hardware issue
or something like that so now
let's talk about
why should you convert your web game
into pwd
so one of the main reasons is after you
have installed
or you have installed the game it should
be
fast on the succeeding calls or once the
page is loaded once
so it should be fast on the succeeding
calls and
it can be engaging as well which i talk
about the previous slide
because you can install it on your phone
or your desktop application
so something like that and accessible so
part of
of being installed it can be accessed
quickly so
and also you can push a push
notification in your game
so whenever you want users to like
inform that you have
new features in my game hey hey steve
and i have a new feature in my game
you should come and check it and play it
again or something like that
so yeah it will be accessible and
engaging in a way
next is what are the steps
um you should consider when you're
creating a
pwa game
so first fish you should fly
so of course whenever you do something
you should plan it
thoroughly so first in modern planning
you should conceptualize what game you
should make
um so concept conceptualizing the game
mechanics and the gameplay so identify
all the game entities so what are
involved in the game does it have a
player and an
enemy or something like that
and tip for um for you
who wants to start your pwa game always
plan small okay
so don't um like don't plan like i'm
going to make a
mobile legend stone using browser or
something like that
always plan small always think of a way
it's fun and
a little bit bigger as
for example you make it a big game
next is of course after planning you
should develop your game
put what you have planned in mind and of
course during the development
you'll see something worth adding and
make it make the
game fun you should add it and of course
when you're developing
you should um develop controls easy for
web
and mobile okay so sometimes
um controls in web should be different
when you have the controls on mobile
so when you're in mobile you should
maximize the swipe
or the gesture animation gesture strokes
the touch animation the touch um stroke
or something like that
but you're hearing web you should
maximize the use of the keyboard
since since it's
easier to play the game in web when
you're using the keyboard
next is of course after you have
developed the game
you should make it pwa so
we're going we're going to set up the
manifest.json
later on i'm going to show a site where
you can easily set up your manifest.json
set up some service workers and of
course
you should compress your images sounds
using compression side
so let's say for example um you have
big png images of course it will
later show some bottleneck in your game
because
it taking up a little time to load so
make it
compress and as little as possible
so
when um when
is always uh here to use libraries like
workbox
bwa so yep
so what are the important things to
consider when doing
a pwa game
so one of the most important things to
consider when you're doing a pwa game
which you should consider responsiveness
so responsiveness as you may think
is quite easy because for you
i think it will be easy
today's web we have a little we have
more power in the css
capability css3 yeah you might be
thinking yeah
it should be easy making a game and make
it
responsive to all devices
but the the thing here is
let's say for example you're developing
a game
and you're developing a game in
a normal resolution which is 20
by 600 pixels and you have this player
sprite
which has a 140 width
and 140 in height
and you want to like when you
when you develop that side
the height and the width
is we switch to mobile
realize that
here a little sprite isn't shrinking at
all
when it comes to mobile because when
you're dealing with canvas
object or elements it will not it's not
easy as
css layer
which automatically shrinks the
sizes of the character or sizes of the
elements
based on the browser's reading height
it's not simple as that
so one way to
solve this problem when you're
developing a video
game and you want it to make you want it
to be responsive in all devices
this um
is to have a skill
viable okay
so let's say for example you're
developing your game
in a you're developing your game it it
looks good
on a height which has 337 pixels
okay so it really looks good when you're
developing it in your
laptop having a size having a height
of three 937 pixels
so what we want to do is we will define
the height
that you're trying to develop your game
which looks good in that height
so let's say for example 937 is the
height
where you develop your game and it
really looks good with that height
having a pixels and 140 pixels in height
and
width of each elements of your beam
so we're going to define
so we're going to define a skill
which will we will pass in every game
entity
that has a height and a width and of
course
it also have an x and y and a velocity
of the entity so what we're going to do
here
is we're going to have the scale so
if your mobile phone is smaller than 937
resolution so we're going to scale down
the game resources that we have
so we're going to device divide the
current
device height to the
base height and the result for that is
we're going to multiply it in every
code that you have
with every code that you have which
correlates to height
or anything to do with coordinates or
pixels
so of course um after we get the
um the scale variable
based on the base height the height that
were used to develop the game
so we're going to have the scale
variable for that
and inside the player class as you can
see here i have this
this that size 200 times this that scale
meaning that i'm going to scale the 200
pixels
based on how how is the
scaling goes so if it's bigger than 137
it should be a little bit bigger than
200 and if your device is a little bit
smaller than 937 pixels
then it should be scaled down to
whatever
value you should derive into so as you
can see here
i have used this skill variable in every
scenario
so i have used in the size i have used
it also in the gravity
so my gravity by a ball should also
scale down
because the pixels that i have in the
game is shrink down so of course the
gravity
should scale down as well the velocity
should spill down as well
or scale up depending on how big the
the screen is and stuffs like that
so next is when you're developing
a pwa game of course it should work in
any platform
but you should also keep in mind
that um you should also keep in mind
that
some games are meant to be played
in landscape or in portrait mode so
you should always or have it's a best
practice to have this screen
so when they're accessing the site or
the game in
um important mode but your game only
looks
great when it's on landscape then you
should prompt them to flip your screen
into portrait or whether landscape or
portrait this
so yep something like that and
yeah if it's flipped to plastic then it
should show the game and
the player can easily play the game
afterwards
um next is change the control
per platform of course when you
when you're doing pwd side you should
have
two controls ready so one control is for
desktop controls which is you're trying
to maximize
the keyboard control
and next is you should also be ready
since you're you cannot use keyboard in
mobile phone
so you should be ready to also cater
the controls for mobile as well so
for mobile so for this game which is the
connect jump
i'm using the left and the left arrow
keys
left and right arrow keys for the
desktop view
and when i'm in mobile since where since
i
told you before that pwa is maximizing
the native
device hardware capability so we can use
accelerometer for controlling the game
in mobile so something like that
and let's go for the little bit of demo
so let me close this slide first
so let's first
go to a little bit demo i'm not going to
put
the game from scratch but i'm going to
show
to you why um this first widely skilled
variable is important
so um we're going to make
a sample for this game um
this game so this game is the conejo
jump
so for you who want to know what the
tech stock for here
is i have used angular 7
power pixel js and p5
so pixi js is the one that i'm using for
the canvas rendering
and i'm using p5 just for the sake that
it has a better
vector what you call this it has a
better vector liability than
pixel or rather pixels doesn't have
vector
library than p5 so
and i also use assets from kenny
so i think you already know who kenny is
when you're into big development kenny
is one of the
big memes when it comes to three assets
of the game
so i have used the assets from penny
yep so that's the code
so i have used angular for this one so
for you angular pips out there is very
straightforward we have this source
folder
you have this app and assets folder
so when you're doing angular
um when you're doing angular
okay let's just make the screen bigger
so it's pretty simple when you're doing
angular and you want to convert your
game or website into pwa
it's simple just like png ad
angular pwa
so angular should take care
of the things that that is necessarily
installed
for you to create the angular pwa
but after you um install your angular
pwa let's cancel that because it's
already installed
so you can see this um two file
which is the manifest.json
and the nsw which is a service worker
configuration
so let's talk about a little bit about
the
manifest.json so
um i have found an easier side
to generate this manifesto json so that
it's
a little bit intuitive rather than
looping the json file
so let's open the site
manifest generator online let's search
for that
let's click here so you can just
google manifest generator online and it
should have something like this
so in a manifest file
um you can define the app name let's say
for example to name a job the short name
um let's say
host is the gallery word for rabbit
called
and display so um display our categories
into four parts when you're
developing a pwa uh do you want it to be
a full screen so for screen meaning it
won't have an
app bar minimal ui standalone in a
browser
so of course we're going to have a full
screen scenes where we want the
experience
to be the same as you're playing a
normal android application
the description is where you put the
description of your game
kids like
job alone the start url
the path where your project should start
and
let's see in the routing in our case we
want the user to access the main route
which is the first round in our game
which is the home component so it should
be
good having this start and and
backslash so for the theme color you can
change
what should be the theme color is
if you want your game to be like purple
you can change it to four points some
people
green in the background or white
anything you want so next is this is the
one that i'm telling you
that if you're trying to make it
installable
to different devices which has different
sizes
you should also prepare icons which is
generated
in multiple sizes so you can clear most
of
the sizes so for in this case
it's pretty easy um you can just find
um you just select a
um you just select an icon of your
preference so let's say for example
images articles players
so let's select this this sad boy here
so let's just drag it into the juice
file
then generate manifest
and you can see here it should generate
a manifest
tip
then you should open the manipulate
extract the files
so once you extract the files um you
should see a manifest folder
you have all the sizes that you want
if you want the game to be installed and
there you have the manifest trees
things that we defined in the website
are already here
we have the theme the background color
the app name the short name the
description
and yeah there you have it and also the
display
so that's the purpose of the
manifestation for you to define
how should your app look like when it's
installed so that's the purpose of
manifest.json so next
is we have the service worker
so service worker in angular
these are the ones that caches
your code or your file so since we're
developing a game
we want to cache the pnt file
the wave 3 the mp3
and if you want to develop a 3d game
also you should cache the obj file
the glps
something like that so you want to push
the obj and tltf since you wanted to
load faster
if you're developing the game but in our
case
we're just developing it 2d
so we won't include that thing and
also this one install mode so we have to
install
mode which is lazy um
sorry we have lazy and
pre-patch so what are the d plants um
lazy or lazy loading is
um it will cache the file once you have
already accept page
or once the the
assets have already been loaded or
showed in the page
then it will cache it but when you say
pre-patch it will catch
the assets before accessing the
assets before accessing the asset so
once you load the page on the
loading process it's already caching the
it's already caching the assets for you
so that that one
and that's basically um the two
configuration when you're
adding a pdw angular is quite easy when
you give it angle
you can also do it immediately without
library but
i highly suggest you use like an android
pwa
or workbox so workbox is
also good when you want to upgrade your
site into pwa
but since we're using angular for this
one we're going to use
of course the um the angular library for
pwa
so the service worker configuration and
the manifestation are the most important
things to consider
when you're developing another
obligation again so next
is the style about um
let's talk about the skill variable
uh okay so there we have i have this max
with 620
meaning that the game looks at looks
good
at 620 pixels so we're going to scale
um we're going to scale our skill
variable based on the max width that we
have
which is it looks good on that
resolution so what if we
just ignore this one and change it to
one
so let's see what will happen
okay
so as you can see here um
let's tap to play so it's
it got a little bit bigger in terms of
player and the sizes so if i try to
convert
the reverted back again to bleed divided
by lock speed
and wait it to reload
you can see here that the player and the
spacing of the dice
got a little bit wider and smaller for
the player
and it's because the um the scale buyer
boiler is the one that's
going to do the work for that is going
to scale down all the necessary things
that
needed to be scaled down in order for
your
game to look good at any devices
so if i'm going to convert it back to
desktop view
and let's reload it again
so you can see here that still
still good for
desktop devices so
let me show the decide for you to play
for it
with it let's see
this one if you want to play with the
game i can show it to you
and
everyone
if you found anybody forgive me for that
because i have
a little time to make the game so i just
made it yesterday
because i really have a tight stage that
works sorry for that
but that's basically the game it works
good
on mobile and web application or desktop
applications
so um and also i have
i have told you that we should cater or
the two scenarios which is if you're in
mobile you should feature the better
controls for mobile
when you're in web you should cater the
better controls program
so in our case um i have used the vice
motion
as an event listener for detecting the
accelerometer of the device
which is loops or player left or right
so it affects the player velocity so the
player should move left or right
depending on
the acceleration gravity in the x-axis
of your of your
phone and also we want to cater
what is best for web or desktop so
i have here for the arrow right arrow
left
so right and left arrows for controlling
the
uh we're controlling this um
rabbit or something like that
so yeah and
i think that's it um
i will just share the code in the also
the chat
so uh okay
i'm sorry this yep i have shared the
whole in the stuff and also in the chat
so if you want to look at a bad code or
something like that so you can check it
you can also have a full request if you
have something to improve
so i think i can now go to
um that's basically it for me